[Musique]
cent quarante septième jour depuis le
déluge seuls les animaux qui ont la
chance de trouver une place sur l'arche
ont survécu tu peux me dire ce que c'est
que ça c'est la même chose qui hier est
celui d'un pareil mais en version prier
pendant qu'ils dégustent ma cuisine il
se déguste pas entre eux
c'est vraiment
[Musique]
des âmes où sur les enfants
la tête
[Musique]
suis réveillé car vous êtes des must
rayons mais je n'avais jamais vu
d'autres industries l'arche elle a
accosté au pk on est mal on ne devrait
pas les aider comme en rond t-il quand
il n'y aura plus rien des cailloux nous
pas des cailloux vous
tu veux nous jeter directement entre les
dents de tes amis carnivores
s'élargit nous a appris quelque chose
c'est bien qu'elle ne faut jamais jamais
chatouiller un hippopotame nain dave ça
nous a appris que c'est tout à fait
possible pour nous les animaux de
dépasser nos différences
[Musique]
si tu vraiment tant pis si monster
j'ai raté un épisode